on
ma journée
non une pause pour ces deux
urgentologues ici
ils sont en première ligne dans une
clinique du mini saute à la musique le
seul remède selon eux pour soigner l'âme
humaine en ces temps difficiles
[Musique]
humain
et partout à travers le blond
spontanément des musiciens se sont donné
rendez-vous pour adoucir cette période
d'isolement forcé si le coach fait mal
si tu ne sais plus rire
si tu ne sais plus être gay comme
autrefois
si le circuit partie le chanteur fred
pellerin réchauffe les coeurs
à maintes fois chez nous je tout rires
sur un balcon de montréal alfa rococo
nous ramène à l'essentiel les choses
on sait que
là bas c'est la gagne
bah
aussi
m
qu'est ce que les joueurs cadres à
l'ouvrier en france jean jacques goldman
dommages aux personnes qui travaillent
dans l'ombre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et cet artiste ougandais rappel en
chanson les précautions à prendre pour
ne pas attraper le virus
on va combattre ce corona chanter jeunes
issus d'afrique à de la musique de
partout qui redonne du baume au coeur
ici aux abords des gares guise radio
canada